PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome
to "Build with Google Cloud,"
where we build things,
reference architectures that
can help you make
your Google Cloud
journey a little bit easier.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Imagine you are
a Cloud architect
for foo.com an internet
accessible application.
There are many different ways
to architect such an application
on Google Cloud.
No one way is right or wrong.
I'm Priyanka Vergadia, developer
advocate here at Google Cloud.
And today, I'm going to walk
you through one such way.
You ready?
Let's go.
[DRILLING]
Let's say our internet-facing
application is foo.com
and our users are accessing
it by typing foo.com
in the browser.
What happens next?
We've written code
for this application
and deployed it on a web server.
Initially, let's say our
application is decently
popular with minimal
functionality
and this one server is
enough to handle the traffic.
Our users will access this
application at foo.com,
but how would the request
reach to the web server?
On the internet,
every single device
has an IP address
which other devices use
to communicate with each other.
The request from
the user's computer
goes to the DNS server,
which responds back
with an IP address that is
used by the user's computer
to then make a
connection to our server.
Great.
But our website also
has some business logic.
For that, we add an
additional application server
to handle some
backend processing,
such as authentication servers,
inventory, payment services,
and things like that.
Then comes the database.
Now, every modern
web application
leverages one or more
databases to store information.
It could be a relational
or nonrelational database,
depending on the type of
data and the use case.
Let's come back to that
in just a little bit.
Now, let's say our app
becomes really popular
and the one server we
have is just not enough.
We need to scale our servers to
handle the increased traffic.
We have two options here.
We could either scale
vertically by increasing
the size of our machines, giving
it more memory and more CPU.
Or we could scale horizontally
by adding more servers
to the equation.
You will find that scaling
horizontally, or scaling out,
is almost always a good
idea because it gives you
more flexibility.
With vertical scaling,
we reach a limit
at a certain point
beyond which we really
won't be able to add
any more memory or CPU.
And at that point, you will
have to scale horizontally.
I would like to
know if you've tried
scaling an application
vertically or horizontally
and how it went.
What was the use
case and why did you
make that choice of
scaling up or out?
Now that we have
more than one server,
we also have more than one IP
addresses for these servers.
So we need something to balance
the load to our servers.
That's where load
balancer comes in.
It distributes the
traffic to the servers.
There are lots of different
algorithms that load balancer
can be set up for, such
as round robin where
routing to the server would
be in a cyclic pattern,
or global where traffic
would be routed based
on where it's coming from.
For example, a request from Asia
is sent to the server in Asia.
Now, weighted weight
load balancing
is based on load
and performance.
For example, if a load on
the server reaches, say, 70%,
send traffic to another one.
And you can add a combination
of a bunch of these rules.
We also add an
internal load balancer
that does the same for our
internal application servers.
Now, let's focus our
attention on the database.
For applications with
heavy transaction
processing where
you need to ensure
that the transactions are
accurate, consistent, isolated,
and durable, also called
ACID, relational databases
should be used.
Relational databases, or
also called SQL databases,
store data in tables.
You have the predefined schema
prior to filling the table
and the tables are linked
with each other through keys.
For applications that
require analysis of data,
nonrelational
databases have emerged
to handle massive
amounts of data
and process it to generate
really meaningful insights out
of them.
Most NoSQL databases
can scale horizontally.
What kind of database are
you using in your application
and why you made that choice?
I would love to know.
Share with me in the comments.
When it comes to scale,
we also reduce load
on the database for the
frequently accessed data.
For this reason,
relational databases
leverage in-memory
database cache.
So the app servers
don't hit the database
for every single
request, rather,
those requests are served
from the database cache,
such as Memcached or Redis.
Now, the next part of the
equation is media files.
We typically never save
our images, video files,
and static content on the
web and application servers.
Such object files are better
stored in an external Blob
storage.
They usually save the
metadata for those objects
as the database and the file
is in the external storage.
Your mobile devices will
need a different image size
and resolution than
your desktop app.
Or you can still have videos
that need transcoding.
For that sort of
processing logic,
you write a function code that
triggers every time a file gets
uploaded into your storage.
Now, consider this.
If a file is
frequently accessed,
say, a popular video or an image
on the website, and your users
are distributed
globally, then you
don't want to access
the file every time
from the external storage.
You would rather want
to cache the file closer
to the user for lower costs,
low latency, and overall better
performance.
Additionally, there might be
push or email notifications
that you need to send to
the user for certain things.
For those, we can use an
asynchronous messaging service,
push notifications
in it, and then
have a server
subscribe to that queue
to send those
notifications out to users
through another service.
Next part of the
puzzle is analytics.
We usually have
two types of data
to ingest into the analytics
system, the real-time data
and the batch data.
The real time could be
content from servers
such as ClickStream data or,
from IoT devices, sensors.
The batch data could
be from your logs.
These are just examples.
What types of real-time
and batch data
are you collecting for
analytics and processing?
Let's discuss more
in the comments.
Once the data is ingested,
we process and enrich it
to clean it up and make it
ready for downstream systems,
then store it in a data
warehouse for further analysis.
Now, data warehouse is a storage
where you keep processed data.
The data from our
databases could also
be aggregated, processed,
and saved in the data
warehouse for further analysis.
You might have heard the
term ETL, Extract, Transform,
and Load.
That's what that is, but ETL is
usually applied to batch data.
Now, data analysts
then analyze the data
and create dashboards
for broader consumption.
And then data scientists and
your machine learning teams
can pick up that data
from the data warehouse
and use it for creating
machine learning
models to generate predictions.
You could also
directly ingest data
from storage systems
for the ML models.
The term that I did not
describe here is data lake.
Do you know what it is and where
does it fit in this puzzle?
Drop it in the comments and
I'll chime into the discussion.
Back to our application.
We also need to make
sure we holistically
monitor our servers at every
part of the architecture
and we need to make
sure all this is
secure in a private network.
Use a firewall to ensure that
the servers that should not
be exposed to the
public internet are not
and the ones that should
talk to each other can.
We also need to make
sure that developers
have the right access
to build the apps,
DevOps teams have the
access to deploy them,
and data analysts have
access to analyze the data,
and other such
access-related rules
around application
security, data security,
and infrastructure security.
Now, if you were
a Cloud architect
for foo.com, how would you
translate this architecture
onto Google Cloud?
There are so many different
ways of achieving the same goal.
No one way is right or wrong.
Let me show you one
of my approaches,
but I would love to know
how you would do it.
I'm sure your approach
is another unique one
that everyone watching
would benefit from.
So share it in the
comments and I'll
chime in if you comment
in the first seven days.
The first thing is to create
a virtual private cloud which
provides managed networking
functionality for all
of our Google Cloud resources.
For our application
infrastructure, the web,
and app servers, we
have multiple options,
depending on multiple factors.
If I have got a small
team of developers,
their time is better
spent coding and not
worrying about infrastructure
and scaling tasks.
Serverless options such
as Cloud Run, App Engine
would be great picks.
Both are serverless and
scale with no effort
as your traffic grows.
Cloud Run offers the ability to
run serverless containers, not
just supporting web traffic,
but also web sockets and gRPC.
If we want to run containerized
apps but with more
configuration and
flexibility, then we
would pick Google
Kubernetes Engine.
It helps us deploy containerised
apps with Kubernetes
without much of a learning
curve while giving us
the control over
configuration of nodes
that we want in
our infrastructure.
GKE also offers
autopilot for when
you need the
flexibility and control
but have limited ops
and engineering support.
The maximum control
option is Compute Engine.
It is straight up
virtual machines.
So we can define the
configuration of our machines
depending on what the amount
of memory and CPU we need.
But this control also
means more responsibility
to scale, manage, patch,
and maintain them as needed.
My recommendation would be to
use Compute Engine for legacy
applications or applications
that require high CPU
and memory with specific
needs in situations that truly
require full control
because you will
need a bigger, better
operations team to manage.
Which of these compute
options are you using today?
And what do you like about it?
I would love to know.
Share with me in the comments.
Now comes the time when
we need to balance load
across our compute choices.
Cloud load balancing
is a fully distributed,
software-defined system.
It can literally respond to over
a million queries per second
and is based on any
past IP address.
What does that mean?
Well, it means that we
can define our frontend
infrastructure with
a single IP address.
If we had global users coming
from, say, Asia, US, Europe,
it can serve requests from a
server that is as close to them
as possible.
It also offers
internal load balancing
for our internal
application servers
so we can route traffic
amongst them as needed.
Right at the load
balancer, we have an option
to enable Cloud CDM to
cache the frequently
requested media and web
content closer to the user
at the nearest edge location.
This reduces latency
and optimizes
for last mile performance
for our users.
It also saves costs by fielding
the request right at the edge
without needing to send
it to the back end.
And Cloud CDN would
be caching content
that is stored in Cloud Storage,
our object store where we store
all of our media assets, CSS,
JavaScript, images, basically
everything static in nature.
Now, Cloud DNS is Google's
infrastructure for high volume,
authoritative DNS serving, which
offers 100% SLA, meaning it
never goes down.
It uses our global network
of Anycast name servers
to serve the DNS zone from
the redundant location
around the world, providing that
high availability and the lower
latency for the users.
This media processing
function can
be deployed on Cloud
Functions, which
is serverless function as a
service that scales as needed
and can be triggered from Cloud
Storage and any other service.
For asynchronous
messaging service,
we would use Pub/Sub and
send messages to a topic
and then the service could
subscribe to that topic
to receive those messages and
send out those notifications
and do other things
with it if needed.
Now, coming to databases,
we have a few choices here.
For relational databases, we
have Cloud SQL and Spanner.
They are both managed.
For generic SQL needs, MySQL,
Postgres, and SQL Server,
Cloud SQL is perfect.
Spanner is best for massive
scale relational database
that needs horizontal scaling.
By massive, I mean thousands
of writes per second
and tens of thousands
of read per second.
And while doing so, it
really also supports
strong consistency and
asset transactions.
I would say you use
Spanner when you
need benefits of both relational
and nonrelational databases.
For nonrelational databases,
we have three major options,
Firestore, Bigtable,
and Memorystore.
Firestore is a serverless
document database
that can be used as
database as a service which
is easy to set up and provides
fast results to complex queries
in real time.
It also supports
offline data and syncs,
which makes it a great
choice for mobile use
cases, along with
web, IoT, and gaming.
Now, Bigtable on the other hand,
is a wide column NoSQL database
that supports heavy
reads and writes
with extremely low latency.
This makes it a perfect
choice for events, time series
data from IoT devices,
ClickStream, event fraud,
recommendations, and other
personalization-related use
cases.
Memorystore is a fully
managed, in-memory data storage
service for Redis and
Memcached at Google Cloud.
It is best for in-memory
and transient data stores
and automates the complex tasks
of provisioning, replication,
failover, and patching, so you
can spend more time coding.
Because it offers extremely low
latency and high performance,
Memorystore is great for
web and mobile, gaming,
leaderboard, social, chat, news
feeds-types of application,
along with in-memory
database caches.
I would love to know which
database options you're using.
Share with me in the comments.
Now comes the analytics piece.
We can ingest the batch
data from Cloud Storage
and real-time data from the
applications using Pub/Sub,
which is serverless
messaging service,
that scales to ingest
millions of events per second.
Data flow can be used for
processing and enriching
the batch and streaming data.
It is based on open
source Apache Beam.
You could use data prep
instead for processing
if you are looking to do the
transformations with the UI
in a no code fashion.
But if you're in a
Hadoop ecosystem,
then Dataproc would be a
better choice for processing.
It is managed Hadoop
and Spark platform
that sets up to Analyze
the data faster instead
of worrying about managing
and standing up your Hadoop
cluster.
We just need to
change that HDFS link
to point to Cloud Storage
and everything else just
works exactly the same as it
would on your Hadoop cluster.
BigQuery is a serverless
data warehouse
that supports SQL queries and
can scale to petabytes of data.
It can also act as your
long-term storage and a data
lake.
We can run SQL queries
to analyze our data
within BigQuery and it literally
queries over petabytes of data
and responds in seconds due
to underlying separation
of that storage
from compute that's
needed to run that query.
We can use this
data from BigQuery
to create a dashboard in
Looker or Data Studio.
It also offers machine
learning capabilities
so we can create ML models
and make predictions by just
writing some SQL statements.
So all in all,
BigQuery is amazing.
If we want, we can do
all our data analytics
with just BigQuery.
Do you do that?
Let me know in the comments.
Now, for machine
learning and AI projects,
we can use the data in BigQuery
to train our models in Vertex
AI or we can import our
media files, images,
and other unstructured data
sets from Cloud Storage as well.
ML/AI, our options depend
really on whether we
want to create our
own custom models
or use pretrained models.
My recommendation is to always
start with a pretrained model.
See if it works for you.
Most common use cases are all
covered, including the images,
text, videos, and tabular data.
If a pretrained
model really does not
work for your use case, then
you can use the AutoML version
within Vertex AI to train a
custom model on your own data
set.
Again, you'll be doing
less coding in this case.
AutoML supports all
your common use cases.
In case you have lots of ML
and data science experience
in-house, that is
only when I would say,
write your own custom model
code in the frameworks
of your choice, TensorFlow,
PyTorch, whatever you choose.
Next.
For operations, monitoring,
debugging, and troubleshooting,
Cloud Operations Suite
offers all the tools
that you need to troubleshoot.
When it comes to
security, understand
that security in Cloud is
a shared responsibility.
Google Cloud offers those
inherent infrastructure
security and tools
that you would
need to protect your
application, your data,
and your software.
Now, how do you make
sure your data is secure?
Well, data is always encrypted,
addressed, and in transit when
on Google Cloud.
You can use confidential
computing VMs
to also encrypt data in use
for sensitive workloads.
You can also bring your own
custom keys for encryption
and there are multiple options
for that with key management
service where you can manage
your own keys in Google Cloud.
You can use external key manager
or hardware security model
for data loss prevention.
And protecting PII
information, you
have DLP which helps mask
and tokenize sensitive data
in BigQuery, Cloud
Storage, or even on-prem.
How do you make sure the right
users have the right access?
For user authentication,
you have Cloud Identity
which checks if the user
is who they say they are.
And for authorization,
you have Cloud IM,
where you can define
who has access to what.
How do you make sure your
applications are secure?
For an application
like foo.com, which
is an internet-facing
application,
the application security
and API security solution
is provided, where
you can use reCAPTCHA
for generating a token.
reCAPTCHA Enterprise
deciphers the token
in the incoming request and then
enforces or allows or denies
the decisions in Cloud Armor.
If Cloud Armor
allows the request,
then it is forwarded to a load
balancer and load balancer
then sends the request
to a respective back end
with Apigee API gateway in the
middle, which allows or denies
or routes API calls based on
client credentials and quotas.
How do you monitor your
systems for security?
Well, Security Command
Center continuously
monitors your Google Cloud
environment for visibility
into the system, it
discovers vulnerabilities,
it detects threats and
then shows that so you
can take action on them.
There's a lot more in security
that I'm not covering here.
Let me know which
topics you would like
to learn more in the comments.
Now, how does CI/CD work?
As a developer, I would write
the code for an application.
I can use Cloud Code
within IDE, push the code
to Cloud Build, which then
packages and tests it,
runs vulnerability scans on
it, binary authorization, then
checks for trusted images.
And once the tests
are passed, it
deploys the package to
staging using Cloud Deploy.
From there, you can create a
process to review and promote
the application to production.
In case of containers,
the container images
are stored in artifact
registry from where they can be
deployed to GKE or Cloud Run.
If you stuck around this
far, then congratulations!
You just learned most of
the Google Cloud Services
for networking, compute,
storage, databases,
data analytics, machine
learning, AI, security,
operations, CI/CD.
There is definitely a
lot more to explore,
but I'm confident this
will get you started
with the right background.
Now it's your turn.
Go build something and share
with me in the comments.
If you like this video, then
I hope you completely destroy
those Like and Subscribe buttons
to let me know I cannot wait
to build more stuff with you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]